devastating
Can someone say that about my channel
someone I Berg and I live
a Mother breaking her silence after a
Clark County teacher was allegedly
recorded threatening to beat up her son
thank you for joining us on this special
early edition of 8 news now I'm Kirsten
Joyce that family is now suing the Clark
County School District in a story you'll
only see on 8 news now Joshua paguera
Joins us live in the studio with the
details Joshua yes hello Kirsten today
this student says he has nightmares we
are protecting his and his mom's
identity because they fear for their
safety
it just blew my mind like I never
thought I would hear somebody say
anything like that like about my son her
14 year old was part of the special
education program at Desert Oasis High
School he started there last August but
then a few weeks later in November the
teen was reprimanded by the teacher who
attorneys identify as Courtney Billups
and that's when the teacher said this
I'd love to get him in a room and just
beat them I'll tell I'll pick him up and
just keep throwing it I just don't like
him these recordings were provided by
the family's attorney at the time of the
teacher's comments the 14 year old who
is Black was kicked out of class after
calling another student who took off his
hood the n-word I'm scared now you won't
communication worker I thought he was
going to do so to me the family says
they shared the recordings with school
police and administrators at Desert
Oasis but nothing was done in the
family's Federal lawsuit they alleged
four claims against CCSD including the
emotional distress Billups and flaked it
on the team but when the kid comes home
telling you oh yeah my teacher said this
he don't like me he keeps saying he's
going to throw me in the trunk he's
going to call his family down here and
kidnap me all this stuff I'm a slave
just believe your kids
yeah that 14 year old no longer is a
student at Desert Oasis and is enrolled
at another school helping him deal with
his anxiety Kirsten thank you Joshua
CCSD has a policy of not commenting on
pending litigation and previously
declined to tell us the teacher Courtney
Billups employment status